okay welcome back everybody
from the break i am happy to
introduce wei who from princeton
university
and uh he's going to talk more about uh
gradient dynamics
but i think from a different perspective
so
take it away okay great
thanks and uh thanks everyone for
joining and uh
thanks to adam and other organizers for
putting together this great
workshop so uh today i'm going to talk
about
my recent work uh that appeared in this
year's new rips
that was last week the the surprising
simplicity of the
early time learning dynamics of neural
networks and uh this is joint work with
lo chao ben and jeffrey all from google
okay so the the previous talk by nadav
has set up the stage really well which
makes
my job much easier so we are interested
in generalization in machine learning
and uh we all learned uh from our first
machine learning course that
we should not use an overcomplicated
model which can overfit to the training
data but generalized poorly to the test
data
and uh this goes back to the outcomes
tracer
uh which says that uh more things should
not be used
than are necessary and uh if we
translate it into the language
of machine learning it is uh just
simpler models generalized better right
but on the other hand uh the modern
practice of deep learning
seems to go against outcomes razer and
oftentimes uh
over parametrized models or which are
highly complex
they all often outperform simpler ones
and in particular uh in many standard
setups the number of parameters in the
model is
much much larger than the number of
samples so for example it's a completely
standard
to train a network with tens of millions
of parameters
on just 50 000 examples for example
so uh it works and it works just fine
and generalizes to the test data
and in these settings uh there actually
exists many solutions
that can perfectly fit the training data
but most of them
do not generalize well to the test data
but
still the solutions found in practice
can often generalize well
so somehow we can find those good
solution solutions
that don't overfit which is very
mysterious
okay now to to resolve this apparent
contradiction
uh as we already heard from nadav's talk
uh we still believe in
outcomes razor and we believe that uh
there's an implicit regularization
effect from the optimization algorithms
we use
so the proposal here is that our
algorithms
that we use such as stochastic gradient
descent or gradient descent
prefers low complexity solutions so in
other words
although our model is very complex but
since we are training it using special
algorithms like sgd
we will only find a low complexity
solution
okay so the the key open question is
what is the right notion of
low complexity in deep learning so i'll
refer to it as
property x we want to find this property
x
so apparently we need to complete
two pieces in order to answer this
question the first are
why does this property x imply good
generalization
and the second question is why does sgd
find a solution with property x
but uh unfortunately uh as far as i know
there's currently still no satisfactory
candidate for property x yet
in general so there have been a lot of
attempts
to obtain generalization bounds for deep
learning uh but
existing generalization bounds based on
various different techniques
they are all vacuous when we actually
evaluate them
in some realistic setups
and moreover uh there's no existing
complexity measure
that can robustly explain generalization
so meaning that now the complexity
measures can
robustly predict the trend of the actual
generalization arrow
across different setups so we are
probably still
not close to fully understanding
generalization in deep learning
but in theory as always we can try to
start from simple settings
for which there's some hope to obtain a
good understanding of
implicit regularization and the
generalization
and hopefully some of the insights there
can generalize to
more complicated scenarios so uh here
are some
uh examples of implicit regulation of
gradient descent in various examples so
um the first example is the simple
linear regression
when the number of features is larger
than the number of samples
so this is a an underdetermined problem
and we know that there are
many global minima and uh it's easy to
show that uh gradient descent with zero
initiation
converges to the minimum two norm
solution so
so the implicit requisition of gradient
descent there is the minimum l2 norm
and the second example is the logistic
regression
on separable data so in that case one
can show that gradient descent
converges to the max margin direction so
the implicit organization is
a maximum margin and uh a third example
is
linear neural networks uh which was what
nadav talked about
so as he mentioned uh like a few years
ago it was conjecture that
gradient descent with near zero
initialization minimizes the nuclear
norm
but uh but now with more and more
studies uh we know that uh
it's actually more complicated and it's
more likely that the inclusive
organization is
uh something similar to low rank okay
and
and and finally there's a line of work
on a type of sufficiently wide neural
networks
and uh there we know that uh gradient
descent with a certain
random initialization is equivalent to a
kernel method
uh known with respect to a kernel called
the neural tangent kernel
so this is also a type of implicit
regularization
and i'll talk more about this later
since uh this is related to this talk
okay so um a hypothesis that's very
related to implicit regulation
which takes a more dynamical viewpoint
is that a
neural network learns functions of
increasing complexity
during training so this says that um
during training
the neural network first learns a simple
function
and it gradually learns more and more
complex functions later on
so one concrete example is again a deep
linear network
so we saw from nadav's talk that
in this case gradient descent can
actually gradually increase the rank of
the solution during training
so as we saw in this plot uh from this
talk
uh the singular values uh they shoot up
one by one
during training so this basically means
that the the rank of the solution is
increasing by one each time
right so this is an example and in in
this talk i'm going to talk about
a new theoretical result uh for
non-linear neural network
also along the lines of this general
hypothesis so we will characterize
how neural network only learns a simple
function in the early time of training
and in particular we showed that in some
natural
settings a nonlinear neural network
trained by gradient descent
only learns a linear function first
before it starts to
learn anything else okay
and uh this phenomenon was not new so it
was already empirically observed
uh in previous work and uh in our work
we
will make it more precise and also give
a rigorous theoretical explanation
okay now let me describe our result at a
high level
so our formal result is for two layer
fully connected network
trained by gradient descent so the
network looks like this
and uh we can have essentially any
nonlinear activation
in the hidden neurons so i'll describe
the precise condition
on the activation later
uh and we also consider a hypothetical
process
which is a linear model also trained by
gradient descent
so this is basically linear regression
and
so this uh the linear model is just a
vanilla linear model on the inputs
with a bias parameter so it just
computes
uh beta 1 transpose x plus beta 2
and beta 1 and beta 2 are the parameters
in this model
and we will also train using gradient
descent
and what we prove is that these two
processes can be coupled
and specifically in the early time of
gradient descent
the neural network and the linear model
compute almost the same function
for input coming from the underlying
data distribution
so basically this is saying that uh the
early time
of training the neural network can be
simulated by
doing this linear regression so
uh in other words although the neural
network has non-linear capacity
it has non-linearity uh gradient descent
will implicitly bias
it towards a simple linear function at
the beginning of training
so this is a very interesting implicit
regulation effect
i have a question so um
okay so right now you're saying this
this is true for any non-linear
activation
but but let's say if i just think about
the relu
um then isn't f and n just a
piecewise linear function so so look i
mean
when you start moving you're going to
start moving on one of the linear piece
which is indeed the linear model well
i'm saying that it's uh the same as
doing a linear regression
over for like for input coming from the
data distribution
so that's a non-trivial uh statement
because it uh like the piecewise
linearity is only like
locally for say some region of the
in the input space
uh i'm i'm not sure i understood
yeah so maybe uh it will be more clear
when i describe the
precise statements sure okay
but also this holds not just for relu
for any nonlinear activation essentially
okay
okay yeah so now uh
before going to the precise statements
let me show you some experiment to
to verify this result so uh we train
a two-layer neural network on some
synthetic data
so this is a setting that can be covered
by our theoretical results
and we also train a corresponding linear
model that's predicted by our
theoretical result
so this plot here shows the losses
during training for these two models
so for the neural network is in blue and
the linear model is in red
and we can see that uh the neural
network and the linear model
indeed have almost the same loss in the
early time
and this is true for for both training
laws and test laws to take all coincide
here and this agreement between the two
models
lasts all the way until the optimal
linear model is found
so at about 1000 iterations uh
the the optimal linear model is found so
the linear regression
in red will stop make stop making
progress
after that and after this point the
neural network will continue to make
progress so it's
learning something non-linear
okay and to see this phenomenon more
clearly uh
this right plot shows the output of the
neural network and the linear model on
five random test inputs
during training so we can see that even
on every individual
input these two models give basically
the same
outputs in the first one something
iterations
so this suggests that uh the neural
network is really computing
a linear function uh over the
data distribution
cool and and and also actually this
phenomena is more general
and we can see it on more complicated
networks and uh
realistic data sets so here i'm showing
a four hidden layer
fully connected network and a four
hidden layer convolutional network
trained on the c410 data set that is a
standard image that said
so similar as before we we plot the
losses and the
the evolution of the outputs and we can
see that both of them can be
well simulated by training a linear
model
so this left plot is slightly different
from before
here we are decomposing the laws into
two parts so the solid curve is the
loss on the linear subspace spanned by
the data and the dashed curve is the
loss
on the orthogonal complement of that
subspace
so we're doing that because we know that
the linear model cannot learn anything
on the orthogonal complement
so it's shown in this red dashed line
and now with this decomposition we can
see very clearly that uh in the early
time
the neural networks are also not made
making any progress
in the complement space so which means
that they are
essentially learning a linear function
up to this point
great so now
now i'm going to describe the formal
setup and the result
and then i will give a proof sketch and
uh discuss the extensions
of this result okay now let's
start with the setup so we consider a
two-layer
neural network and the input dimension
is d the input is x from rd
and we let m be the width of the network
so that's the number of neurons in the
hidden layer
and we let the first layer weight be w
which is an
m by d matrix and the second layer
weight is v
is which is an m dimensional vector and
the output of the network is this
function of the input and the the
weights w
and v so this is a standard uh two-layer
neural network
and there's a non-linearity phi
applied on every hidden euro so there
are these scaling factors uh one over
root m and one over root d
uh they are due to the so-called ntk
parametrization
and so in this parametrization we can
initialize all the parameters with
variance one
and these scaling factors can make sure
that the variances at the
hidden neurons and the outputs do not
blow up at initialization okay
and the the specific uh initialization
we use
uh is this anti-symmetric random
initialization
uh which was used by several previous
works so here uh what we do is to
divide the network into two halves and
the first half which is neuron
one through m over two uh is initialized
randomly and the second half is
initialized as the opposite of the first
half
so basically this can ensure that uh the
output of the network is always zero at
initialization
for any input x okay so this can make
things a lot cleaner and and
usually by doing this uh we can actually
improve the performance so this is the
setting
we will work with okay so now
for the activation function phi we
require that uh
it's either a smooth function and
specifically we need it to have
bounded first and second order
derivatives
or it's a piecewise linear function like
relu and
liquidu so this covers all the commonly
used activation functions
like rilu sigmoid tangh and so on
so so basically this means we can allow
any
nonlinear activation
cool so so next uh i will specify the
assumptions on the data so we have
n samples x i y i from 1 to n draw an
iid from
a distribution and x i's are the inputs
and y i's are the labels
and we assume that the input has 0 mean
and covariance matrix sigma so i write
gaussian here but
it's not important and it can be
generalized to subgaussian
or some bounded moment conditions so
this is basically for the purpose of
some
concentration arguments using the proof
but we don't need to worry about them
today and we also assume that the trace
of the covariance sigma
is normalized to the dimension d and
also the the other eigen values of sigma
are of order one so this means that the
covariance is well conditioned
and we we assume that the labels are
bounded but other than that there's no
other assumption on the labels so
basically we don't
assume anything on how the labels are
generated
okay so then under this data assumptions
it's
uh very standard to show several
concentration properties
that's satisfied by this input data
if the dimension d is sufficiently large
so first
the norms of the xi's are concentrated
around square root d and second
every pair of x i and x j are nearly
orthogonal to each other
and we let third we let capital x
be the n by d data matrix then
the empirical covariance matrix which is
uh one over n
x transpose x should also have all the
eigen values
of order one because uh it will
concentrate around the true covariance
which is sigma okay and this property
requires
uh n to be larger than d so
here we just assume that n is greater
than d to the power one plus epsilon for
some small constant epsilon
and and we throughout we also assume
that n is upper bounded by
uh polynomial in d
okay so so that was all the assumptions
and uh we use uh the standard l2 loss
function for training
which is defined here and for now
uh we just consider gradient descent
only on the first layer weights
w so we fix the second layer v to
initialization
and only update the first layer w using
gradient descent with learning rate eta
and we do have similar results when the
second layer is also trained
but that one is slightly more
complicated so i'll just
i'll go to that later so for now let's
just train the first layer
okay and finally we let ft be the
network uh with a function computed by
the network at iteration t
so it is defined using the the weights
that's the t
iteration
cool so remember that uh we want to
couple the neural network training with
a hypothetical process of training a
linear model
so now let me specify uh what is the
linear model
so the linear model is the f link
defined here
so as i promised is a linear function on
the input x
except that there's a there's a scaling
factor one over root d
and some scaling constants uh zeta and
mu
so uh these are definitions of theta and
mu they are constants that depend on the
activation function
and new also depends on the data
covariance sigma
okay so so these factors basically
enable us to use the same learning rate
here
uh here as in the neural network
training so
uh if we don't want these scaling
factors we can remove them but then we
need to adjust
the learning rate appropriately uh so
that we still get the same dynamics
okay so but but
anyway this is still uh equivalent to
doing the linear regression
and we still use the l2 loss and we
update the parameters beta using
gradient descent starting from zero
and finally we let f lin t with the
linear model that we obtain at
iteration t
so now we are ready to see the results
so remember that our goal is to prove
that these two processes are close to
each other
so basically we want to prove that f t
and f lin t
are close so here is the precise theorem
so uh we assume that uh the width
m is greater than d to the power one
plus epsilon
for some small constant epsilon so
basically we want the
width to be slightly larger than the
input dimension
and for the learning rate r is uh we
need it to be smaller than order d
and i'll say what that means later
and then for all iterations t from zero
to this capital t uh which is d log d
over epsilon
we have that uh the neural network ft
and the linear model of lin t are closed
in the following sense
so first uh they are closed on the
training data x1 through xn
so we show that uh this mean square
arrow on the training data
is smaller than d to the power minus
omega epsilon
because we assume epsilon is a small
constant
then when d is large uh this arrow will
go to zero
so these two models make uh basically
the same
predictions on the training data and
second
we show that they're also close on the
underlying distribution
where the data are drawn from okay so we
show that
the expected squared arrow also with a
truncation
this expectation is small okay and the
expectation is for
uh x drawn from the input distribution
okay so so the truncated loss here uh is
for some technical reason which i think
might not be very important
but but anyway this this is still a
valid choice of loss
and this result uh qualitatively means
that
uh ft and flinty are close
on the entire input distribution
okay let me mention a few remarks
so we in this result we have this
agreement between the two models up to
iteration capital t so we need to
understand what this means
and uh actually after t iterations the
linear model
f link will already reach a near optimum
so notice that uh this is just a linear
regression so
uh it's very easy to show this
convergence
so uh this means that uh the
neural network first exactly learns the
optimal linear model
so that's because we know that at
iteration capital t
the neural network is close to the
linear model and the linear model will
basically the same as the optimal linear
model so in other words
uh the neural network performs the
entire linear regression
before it does anything else
uh and uh second i want to emphasize
again that there's no assumption
on the labels y i so whatever y is are
the neural network will try to do a
linear regression
to fit the y eye
and the the third remark is that uh we
the width requirement that we have
uh that uh width is slightly larger than
the input dimension is
a very mild assumption uh and uh that's
typically satisfied
so um we don't need the width to be very
large
in particular we don't need to depend on
the number of samples
and i'll say more about these points
later
and the the the final remark is that uh
about this learning rate we need it to
be smaller than order d
and the order d is actually the largest
stable learning rate
so that means if the learning rate is
much larger than d
uh the training will be unstable and the
loss will blow up
so we so our result can allow the
largest possible learning rate
within a constant factor
okay is there any question at this point
so is it clear what happens after
capital t
uh no it's not no we are
we don't have any characterization
so it doesn't follow from any result for
ntk that something
better no no yeah so if the if the width
is super wide we know
it uh follows the ntk but uh if not so
why then
it can differ from that
thank you yeah so so
now i will give a sketch of the proof so
our proof
um as i said is inspired by the theory
of
uh ntk neural tangent kernel so i'll
first uh
very quickly explain what that is so the
ndk
theory says that a sufficiently wide
neural net trained by gradient descent
is equivalent to a kernel method with
the neural tangent kernel
and so we probably all know that the
idea of kernel method
so is to map an input x to some other
feature space
hx which can have very high dimension or
infinite dimension
and the kernel method is to try to learn
a linear function of
h and we can do either regression or svm
in this feature space
and the kernel trick says that in order
to do that we only need to compute
this kernel function which is the inner
product in this feature space and we
don't need to actually work with the
feature space which can have very high
dimension
okay so now the the main idea of ntk is
to consider
a linearization of the network around
the randomly
initialized parameters so what does this
mean
um we let f theta of f x theta in the
neural network so
this theta is the parameters and the x
is the input
and we also let us theta init be the uh
be the parameters at random
initialization
and what we do is a first order taylor
expansion around theta init
and we will get this and uh
notice that uh we we can ignore the
first term
because uh recall that we can make the
initial output zero
by doing this anti-symmetric
initialization
so we don't need to worry about this
zeroth order term
so this is the approximation we get and
now if we just pretend that
this approximation is accurate then
this right hand side is actually linear
in the parameters theta and we can view
it as a
linear model in this blue feature vector
the blue feature vector is the gradient
of the network with respect to the
parameters
and we evaluate it at the at the random
initialization point
so corresponding to this uh feature is
this uh
kernel function uh and this is the the
so-called neural tangent kernel
okay and uh so uh if this accurate
uh this approximation is accurate we
know that uh
we will get a kernel regression with
this kernel
and we still need to justify this taylor
expansion
and uh in fact we can show that uh if we
run gradient descent
this approximation uh will be valid
during the entire training process
if the neural net is sufficiently wide
and the width
requirement of the width uh there
usually needs to be very very large
for this theory to hold for example uh
most of the time it needs to be depend
at least polynomially on the number of
samples
and and also some other quantities so
this is a much
more unrealistic assumption than what we
assumed in our theorem
so for that we only need the width to be
larger than the input dimension
and we don't need to uh we don't need it
to depend on the number of samples and
okay so so that was a quick summary of
ntk so when this uh
ntk theory holds because we know that we
are doing
a kernel method with this kernel k uh we
know that
uh the the kernel matrix uh capital k
so which is the and by n matrix uh that
contains the kernel function evaluated
on all the
training samples x one through x n so
this kernel matrix
will determine the behavior of training
okay so now the the main idea in our
proof
is to show that uh the neural network
and the linear model
have similar ntk matrices
okay so these are the two models so
first we can compute uh
their anti-case so by the previous
definition we we just want to compute
the kernel function corresponding to
this gradient feature
so here we only need to take the
gradient with respect to w because we
only
we are only training the first layer w
and uh
this this is the expression we get for
the kernel function
and for the linear model we can also
easily
compute the kernel function this scaling
which is
basically just the inner product
okay and then we can compute the matrix
the kernel matrix
uh on the training data which is this
capital k
so that's an n by n matrix and
also here for the linear model we can
also compute the
kernel matrix k length so it's just a
linear combination between
the linear kernel xx transpose and
the one matrix one one transpose
okay and now we want to show that uh
these two
matrices are in some sense similar
and uh what we show exactly is that
is this uh key lemma so the lama says
that with
high probability over the the randomness
in the initialization and the randomness
in the training data
we have that uh the difference between
these two and by n matrices
uh k and k link the difference has
operator norm
upper bounded by n over d to the one
plus epsilon
okay so now let's look at uh what this
lambda means
so i will illustrate it using this plot
which shows all the eigen values of
k and k lin in in example
so here the eigen values of k are in
blue
and the eigen values of k link are in
orange
so notice that first notice that uh this
matrix k link
has rank only d plus one because uh
xx transpose is rank d and the or matrix
is rank one
okay so that's why in this plot we see
that kling only has about
100 non-zero eigenvalues that's because
d is 100.
and moreover uh we know that all the
nonzero eigenvalues of k-link
should be of order n over d so that's
because we know the
we know all the eigen values of x x
transpose uh
should be order n from the concentration
of the empirical covariance of the data
so that i previously showed so
also this one line transpose also uh has
a eigenvalue order n so this uh this
entire matrix have uh all the non-zero
eigen values
uh and over d okay now
if we look at this lemma uh what's what
it says is that
uh k the kernel matrix k
is equal to k length plus this
perturbation matrix and this
perturbation only has
operator norm bounded by n over d to the
one plus epsilon
which is much smaller than an over d
when d is large
so that means that uh the perturbation
will not affect
the top singular top eigen space
of kalin and it may create many small
eigen values
but the small eigenvalues are all
smaller than unknown d
to the one plus epsilon so this is why
we are seeing this uh
eigen structure of k uh where the top
eigen space
is the same as scaling uh but uh
and also there's a there's a clear eigen
gap between these tops
eigenvalues and the other small
eigenvalues so this is
uh implied by this lemma okay so now
with this lemma we can finish the proof
uh in a few more steps
so first uh if we were to do a kernel
regression
with the kernel k then the proof is done
so this is because uh in kernel
regression we know that uh
the top eigenspace is learned faster
than the bottom eigenspace
and here because there's a significant
gap in the eigenvalues
there will be some point where almost
everything in the top eigenspace is
learned
but almost nothing in the bottom
eigenspace is learned so at that point
uh
because the the top eigenspace is
basically the same as scaling
uh we actually know that uh what we
learn is a linear function
so we are doing a linear regression
okay so uh now uh
the second step uh because we're not
really doing
kernel regression with k we're training
a neural network
so we still need to show that our trend
in the neural network before iteration t
is close to doing this linear regression
and uh
in order to show that we need to show
this uh linearization approximation that
i
showed uh when i introduced ntk we need
to show that
this approximation is accurate in some
sense
so actually we have to show this uh very
carefully
and uh we for for this reason for our
theorem to work
so we actually need to bound the average
arrow over the training data
as well as some imaginary test data so
the the point is that uh we need to do
this very carefully and we just
uh we if we only bound this arrow on
every individual data point
uh we will get a much worse width
requirement we will not get uh
m greater than d okay
and there are a few more uh technical
remarks so
the first one is that um the reason that
we only require
this uh a very mild with requirement
m greater than d uh is because we only
care about the
top eigen space of the kernel and we
only care about the early time of
training
so uh we if uh
in other words we don't uh we don't say
anything about uh what's happening in
the
bottom magnet space so as long as the
top space is not affected uh
our result will be valid
and uh the the second remark is that uh
uh we can't we could try to more naively
bounce the
the operator norm of this difference by
like bounding the frobenious node
but but that will not be enough because
the frobenius norm will scale like a
number d
and this is a this is tight and if we
use this as an upper bound this will not
be
enough for our purpose because it can uh
mess up with the top eigen space
so the the point is that we have to
bound this operator norm
uh in a more careful way than bounding
the forbidden snow
okay is there any more
is there anything wait i didn't i didn't
see where you used any properties of the
activation
if you were to just do kernel regression
are you going to soda
yes we are so that's why it's a
general is a general property that holds
essentially for any activation but the
the like the zeta and
new constants here remember that they
depend on the activation function
so like for any activation we can have
this kernel
and we show that it's it's a it's
approximately the same as
a particular k-link so but the the
constant here depends on the activation
okay yeah yeah that's the only place
this comes in
actually in fact like for some
activation functions
this data will be zero for example if
say
if you look at the sine function sine of
cosine
for then this theta will be zero so that
means that we will not be able to learn
a linear function yeah but for
for as long as this is not zero this
property will hold
great yeah so so that was the result for
training the first layer and now we will
move to training the second layer only
and after this it will be very clear how
to handle the case of
training both layers okay so so now we
fix the first layer to initialization
and only train the second layer using
gradient descent
so what changes now is that we will have
a different corresponding linear model
for this process which is defined here
so i put linear in quotes because uh
i like before this is not exactly a
linear model in the input x
that's because there's this additional
blue coordinate here
which depends on the norm of the input
right so this linear model is linear in
x as well as this blue feature
so in this blue feature uh you may
notice
so these are the and these are the
constants that appear
in this uh definition so again they
depend on the activation function
so you may notice that these last two
terms
uh have only have smaller order than the
first term
because because of this concentration
property of the norm of the input
but it's still necessary to include
these two terms
and otherwise the the theory will not
work
and and uh yeah we actually construct an
example to illustrate that uh
it's necessary to include this normal
dependent feature
so so here's the example so in this
example we
let the labeling function uh to generate
the data uh
explicitly depend on the norm of the
input so
this is the function that we use to
generate the data
and this plot shows uh the test losses
of three models when we try to
fit this data so the first model is the
neural network with
relu activation which is in blue
and and we train the second layer of the
of this network
and the the second model is this red one
is
the linear model predicted by this uh
by this theory so this is exactly what i
write here
this is in red and the third model is a
naive linear model
which is uh the same as this except that
we remove
this last two terms which depends on the
norm of the input so it's the naive
linear model is a
real linear model on the input and
clearly here we see that
the linear model that we predict is a
much better approximation
to the neural network than the naive
linear model
so this is uh
this is reasonable because we expect
that this feature can help
learn this uh this this label that
depends on the norm of the input
okay so this means that it's necessary
to
include uh this non-linear feature uh in
in the definition of this linear model
okay so that that was the case for
training the second layer
so now with this results are for
training first and second layers it's
very easy to obtain the corresponding
linear model for the case of
training both layers so basically we can
just combine the previous
uh two linear models and get the
corresponding linear models
here so that's because the the ntk for
training
both layers is the sum of the two ndks
for training the first layer and for
training the second layer
and it's it's very easy to to write down
the corresponding linear model
uh whose kernel is the the sum of the
previous two linear kernels
right and and also we can allow
different learning rates in both layers
so that was for the same learning rate
uh if
if we have different learning rates in
two layers uh we will just get
a weighted combination of these two ntks
and of course we can uh in a very
straightforward way write down the
corresponding
linear model to to respect this weighted
combination
if we have different learning rates
right so finally let me uh briefly
mention
some extensions so we saw that the
general principle
behind this linear learning behavior in
the early time of training
is that the top eigenspace of ntk
agrees with the linear kernel xx
transpose
and we have some more theoretical
evidence which shows that
this property also generalizes beyond
two layer fully connected networks to
multi-layer fully connected and
convolutional neural networks
but the theory especially for
convolution network
is not complete yet
and but we can already verify this
behavior empirically so like uh
including even on real data sets
so like what i showed in the beginning i
showed some experiments
of of multi-layer convolution mass and
fully connectedness on the c410 data set
and we can also try to explain this uh
behavior for real data sets
because we can still look at their
corresponding ntks and
to see if this top eigenspace agreement
behavior
is still true so for example here i'm
showing the the
the uh the eigen values for
k and k link for the mnist and the c410
data set
so what what we found uh here is that uh
there's still a
pretty clear agreement between the
kernels
but it's not as nice as the synthetic
data that we saw before
and in particular there isn't an eigen
gap
uh in the in the spectrum but but still
this agreement can explain to some
extent why we are seeing
the same linear learning behavior on
these real data sets
cool so now let me conclude
so we we proved a new result that
characterizes the
implicit regulation of gradient descent
so we show that
in some natural settings a nonlinear
neural network
does linear regression in the only in
the early time of training
okay and we saw that the underlying
reason for this phenomenon
is the top eigenspace agreement between
the ntk of the neural network and the
linear kernel
and this phenomenon seems to hold quite
generally
and on the technical side we also saw
that the
theory of ntk which was originally used
for
studying very wide neural networks or
infinitely wide networks
it can still be useful even at a small
risk if we
are trying to characterize the early
time of training
and and finally a very interesting
question
uh which uh what which was asked during
the talk
is that uh what what happens after the
learning linear learning period
and we we know that uh uh this
this period cannot be characterized by
the ntk anymore
because the width is small and we see
that the ndk can change a lot
so what what is it
and that's all i have
okay thank you very much any questions
for way
uh so could you talk a bit about the
role of the imaginary
test points in your approximation
uh yeah sure so we want to show
uh like these two models are closed uh
on the
entire distribution and we
but here maybe let me go to that point
so here uh like this closeness between
the
neural net and this linearized
approximation
uh we if we want to show the tight
behavior
of this approximation we need to show it
on average over some
training data or or over some test data
but it's not enough to show it on
individual
data points so that's why we we take
we uh we take imaginary test data sets
which contain many
test data points and we show that
they're close uh
on average on those test data points and
then we
move it back to the to the entire uh
data distribution
like using a concentration argument but
i don't think that
that approach is necessary i don't think
so i think we can directly
handle the test distribution so i'm
confused about the fact that
you i thought your theorem did claim
that you if you only average over the
training data uh the two
like the linear and the you know neural
nets are close
right you made a claim both about the
training
site yes and separately about the test
set
yes so so you so the test set
is for showing the the agreement
on the data distribution so that this
the test imaginary test data is used for
showing the second
one so on the average over the training
it holds them
just yeah on the training data it holds
yeah we don't need
tested okay this is only for showing the
organization basically
any other questions
okay we'll meet back in 13 minutes and
satan will give us
uh more of an algorithmic perspective on
these topics see you then